Democrats have settled on a final
desperate midterm strategy called
Republicans racist second verse same as
the first proving the age-old Maxim when
a left winger calls you a racist you
know that you've won the argument we
will examine the final midterm arguments
and the crucial difference between
Republican and Democrat campaigns in
2018 there's one very big difference
then the mailbag I'm Michael Knowles and
this is the Michael Nolt show welcome to
my dungeon I know I invite you into my
boudoir a lot now you're in my dungeon
studio look a little different first of
all on the one hand the good news is I'm
free from my broom closet the bad news
is I'm now in a cave somewhere in Tora
Bora or something we're here there's
some construction going on at the
studios right now and I kind of like the
idea that were in this bunker until the
midterm elections were in the war room
regardless of what happens even even if
Republicans hold the Senate even if the
Republicans hold the house the deluge of
leftist tears could be so intense that
the leftist here's tumblr wouldn't even
be able to sustain them now we're in
sort of one giant leftist here's tumblr
a leftist here's silo if you will we
have a lot to get to today president
Trump is coming out swinging he's
fighting to the very last minute in
these midterm elections he's
nationalized this election which is a
huge win Democrats are using the only
trick that they've got which is to call
conservatives racists will analyze race
by race but first let's make a little
money honey what time is it oh it's time
to make a little money honey okay
you know how I know that because of my
movement watch you know how much I love
the movement watches founded by those
two college dropouts that started their
own watch company the company has grown
like crazy they have now sold almost two
million watches in a hundred 60 plus
countries they continued to
revolutionize fashion on the belief that
style shouldn't break the bank I was at
a party last night I saw a guy he didn't
even listen to the show just wearing one
of his little movement watch as I
complimented him on his he complimented
me on mine I get a ton of compliments on
this thing this is the Atlas revolver I
think it's the coolest watch they've
made but they're a bunch of others that
I want that they still haven't sent me
so go over get them yourself you know
maybe send one over here I don't know
liber8 Republicans hopefully picking up
seats in the Senate movement watches
were all about looking good and keeping
it simple they don't tell you how many
steps you've taken they don't you know
blow up your wrist with text messages
and you got to call your mother back or
whatever you got to do not that at all
they tell the time like a watch is
supposed to do movement watches start at
just 95 bucks at a department store
you'd be spending four or five hundred
bucks for this today get 15% off with
free shipping and free returns by going
to movement
MVM t.com slash co f f/a co v fe fe cy
movement keeps growing check out their
expanding collection go to movement
MVM t.com slash co f fa co v fe fe and
join the movement so right now for these
races I won't go through all of the
polling but right now there are some
there are some real movement in the
Republican direction on Senate races
there was a really tight Senate race in
Indiana and Joe Donnelly just made a few
racist comments legitimately racist
comments because he said he said I've
got a staffer who's african-american but
she does a good job I've got a staffer
who's Indian but he does a good job
actually you just kept repeating it so
that one's tightening up West Virginia
looks like it's in a dead heat right now
we've got Republicans way up in North
Dakota we've got Republicans up in
Missouri I believe there's just there's
a lot of movement going on as for the
house cook Political Report is now
revising up the number of seats that
they think Democrats are going to take
they now think that at the outer limit
Democrats could take 40 seats this is up
from there prediction at 35 seats to put
that into historical perspective Barack
Obama lost 63 seats in his first midterm
election Bill Clinton lost 54 seats in
his first midterm election so it's not
outside the realm of possibility
actually if the Democrats win 30 seats
all in all that's a that's a sort of a
win for the Republicans historically
speaking that means they held on to a
lot of seats I'm not sure even that is
going to happen the Democrats have to
flip 24 seats in order to take the house
I don't know I don't want to make any
predictions I don't want you know who
knows we actually still have a few days
things could change these races are also
close
I'm not convinced Republicans are gonna
lose the house I'm not convinced at all
I think we're not in normal times I
think that the polling is reliable when
you're in normal times and right now
we're not in normal times this election
has become a referendum on Donald Trump
Trump has done that and the media have
been happy to oblige they've they've
made it a national election about Trump
and right now the left has gone so
insane that it's socially unacceptable
to say that you support Donald Trump in
a lot of places it can hurt you at your
job it'll certainly hurt you at your
university it can hurt you with family
members so people don't say it you've
got leftist mobs in the street so I'm
not sure that I really believe the
polling I'm not sure that people are
gonna tell pollsters that they're
willing to support the Trump agenda
we'll have to see well we'll be here on
election night but Donald Trump is going
down to the wire with a brutal campaign
ad I think it is superb in typical Trump
e fashion it's not not the most subtle
not the most subtle ad in the world and
they are focusing this election just
like they did in 2016 on immigration
this is the final argument being made
the Cavanaugh effect was very helpful to
us the judges the mob violence all of
that is a good argument but they're
making this about immigration as this
illegal caravan is going up through
Mexico here is the ad
I can narrate this for people who can't
read it Democrats let him into our
country he just killed two he wishes he
killed more of those blanks I'm gonna
kill more cops soon Democrats let him
stay
[Applause]
if they don't better don't she says he
wants to apply for partner for the
Thuggee who committed that choice do you
see this Caravan moving up he's saying
you're seeing criminals you're seeing
young men creating violence in this
Caravan says who else would Democrats
let in there's this smiling illegal
alien cop killer President Donald J
Trump and Republicans are making America
safe again brutal devastating campaign
ad and absolutely right how do you think
the media are responding to this add
iview I'll give you one guess two
syllables what is it it's racist that's
what they're saying it's racist which is
sort of ironic because the claim that it
is racist is itself racist we'll get to
that in a second what they're really
claiming I mean everybody is saying is
shockingly racist add the most racist ad
in 30 50 a thousand years okay what is
the claim of the ad the claim of the ad
is we shouldn't let these illegal aliens
thousands and thousands of them barge
into the country break our laws
illegally the claim is that there are
some criminals among them the claim is
that some of these criminals have not
been deported they've been allowed to
stay and they've committed more crimes
all of that is true here's what you need
to know number one illegal aliens commit
a disproportionate share of federal
crimes
period it is often alleged on the left
that illegal aliens commit fewer crimes
than native-born Americans
it depends what studies you're looking
at it depends how you calibrate those
data but we do know that they commit a
disproportionate share of federal crimes
21% of non-immigration crimes are
committed by non-citizens that is over
two and a half times their share of the
population now look a lot of most crimes
are staying local crimes okay but as for
federal crimes they commit two and a
half times their share of the population
worth of crimes non-immigration crimes
now there are some conflicting studies
there is a study out from the Cato
Institute that shows lower rates of
violent crime among illegal aliens
however the Crime Prevention Research
Center shows significantly higher rates
of violent crime
illegal aliens so you've got different
studies this is why conservatives tend
not to rely on social scientific studies
too much because they can be manipulated
they're easily politicized as I believe
it was Mark Twain said there are lies
damned lies and statistics number two
that you need to know lefties are
pretending now that illegal immigration
actually reduces crimes you'll see it
sounds like the same argument but it's
not the one argument is that illegal
aliens commit less crime the other is
that illegal immigration decreases crime
over time there is there's a correlation
between crime decreasing in America and
illegal immigration increasing
correlation is not causation so you see
this in New York Times all of the
mainstream media reporting on this and
it's true as over the last thirty years
illegal immigration has increased
dramatically and crime has decreased
okay Apple computers have gotten faster
to illegal immigration increases the
speed of Apple computers you know over
that time vegan coffee shops have
increased as well illegal immigration
results in a higher percentage of vegan
coffee shops of course not
there are different trends that are
happening crime has fallen in the United
States violent crime over the last
thirty years
dramatically this is not because we've
led a lot of illegal immigrants into the
country and illegal aliens are residing
here and there like Tibetan monks or
something you know they're come on all
we are saying is give peace a chance
that's not what they're that's not what
they're saying those are two different
trends and they're not related number
three
Cato Institute observes that legal
immigrants are less likely to be in jail
or prison in the u.s. the point being
that it's all of this immigration
illegal and illegal should be encouraged
that's how the left is using that
statistic no it just means that legal
immigrants are very law-abiding and what
the left always tries to do this is why
they change the language here it's why
you now have to say undocumented
immigrant or dreamer or whatever instead
of illegal alien is they want to
conflate illegal immigrants with legal
immigrants but they aren't the same
thing
they're not immigrants they're they're
foreign nationals who are here illegally
they are not immigrants and illegal
aliens behave differently than legal
immigrants to the United States
obviously so the first act of an illegal
alien in the u.s. is to break a
fundamental law legal immigrants from
the same countries from the same exact
places
wait online respects the law of the
United States and they tend to be more
law-abiding this is no shock at all I
mean the one thing we know about these
two groups is one of them follows the
law and one does not follow the law and
it's a little sleight of hand that the
left does because they say look
immigrants commit far less crime okay
but what about illegal aliens those are
totally different questions and this
this one hasn't been reported the fourth
thing you should know the Guatemalan
president president of Guatemala has
said publicly that he has caught Isis
trying to caught Isis operatives in his
country presumably to join the caravan
and enter into the United States unless
they just wanted to go for the really
delicious guatemalan food I don't know
what else they were doing down there if
not to attack the United States he has
said Jimmy Morales the president of
Guatemala that he has caught and
deported 100 nearly 100 Islamic
terrorists in his country just within
the last month just right before that
that Caravan was moving from Honduras
into Guatemala
eventually into Mexico he says that he
caught 100 isis-affiliated Islamic
terrorists there did he I don't know is
the president of Guatemala telling the
truth I don't know what incentive does
he have to lie I I don't really think he
has any incentive to lie either what I
can promise you is that you have not
seen that reported in the mainstream
media and actually the one time I think
Pete egg Seth on Fox and Friends
mentioned this and the media piled on
they said how dare you report this how
dare you report this well the president
of Guatemala said it that's what that's
all we're saying and why won't you cover
what the president of Guatemala who is
there who knows a lot more about this
Caravan than you do Chris Cuomo or Don
Lemon or brian Stelter or anyone else on
CNN why aren't you reporting them
because it contradicts the narrative
that these are all peaceful loving
mothers and their Shahrukh children who
just
want a better life who love America and
want to come here and eat apple pie and
go to baseball games that is not the
case the reality from all the videos
we've seen of this Caravan and from the
testimony of the president of Guatemala
contradicts that another thing you
should know is that there are a ton of
criminals in here in Guatemala the
Guatemalan authorities have saved seven
children from human traffickers who are
bringing them into the United States to
do whatever horrific nefarious things
that these people do that human
traffickers and coyotes will do with
them so they've only caught seven I hope
I hope they can rescue more but who
knows how many they are there are this
is the trouble with unvetted random
violent mobs trying to break their way
into the country is there's no vetting
you have no idea who these people are
you don't know their criminality you
don't know the relationship of these
adults to the children so the Democrats
demagogue all the time they say you're
separating families at the border you're
separating this father from his son yeah
maybe maybe you are do you know that do
you know that that little girl is the
daughter of that man no you don't know
that at all there aren't any documents
this is why we have legal structures to
make sure that the people who aren't
coming to the country or who they say
that they are and that we're protecting
kids we know the statistic I mentioned
it a lot but I mentioned a lot a lot
because the mainstream media won't which
is that 60 to 80 percent of women and
girls according to Amnesty International
and Fusion in the Huffington Post
are sexually assaulted when they cross
the border into the US illegally so
clearly we don't know that the little
daughter belongs to the father coming in
here Guatemalan authorities have
arrested or have arrested a number of
traffickers and rescued seven kids
that's good
we also know that Mexico once the
caravan made it into Mexico has arrested
and deported two fugitives wanted for
murder we know of just to who knows how
many more there are you saw the video
you saw it wasn't a lot of women and
children was it it was young men getting
very violent at borders okay the the
last thing you should know about this
the majority of Americans want this
Caravan stopped all public polling has
suggested this
I think that the latest poll is that 51%
of Americans want this stopped they
don't want anybody let into the country
38% wants some people to be let in and
have their cases heard and see if they
qualify for asylum or this this or that
or the other thing so you've got that's
a significant margin
you've got the majority of the country
doesn't want this
that's Republicans that's Democrats
that's independents this is why
President Trump has identified this
issue is so important because maybe he
hasn't read Edmund Burke or Michael
Oakshott or gone to Heritage Foundation
lunches but he does know that people
really care about this it's so offensive
and it is a real danger you know I think
when when these girls Cady Steinle was
killed by an illegal alien Molly Tibbets
I think was another one killed by an
illegal alien
whenever president Trump would point
that out he'd be talking about how often
illegal immigration is what it danger it
is to the country then the left would
say there's no danger at all and then
some American citizen in those cases
young girls were killed by illegal
aliens and the left would say oh that's
just convenient that's just an anecdote
these girls aren't anecdotes they're
American citizens who are who are dead
because of the horrific reckless anti
American anti policies of Democrats
that's why
okay people make mistakes politicians
make mistakes all the time
politicians can support disastrous
policies okay but then stop stop
supporting the policy turn around
support a different policy a lot more to
get to on this question but first I've
got to make a little money honey then we
can analyze all of the sad desperate
empty arguments in the homestretch of
these midterm elections but first
speaking of safety and making
neighborhoods safer we got to think ring
rings mission is to make neighborhoods
safer today over a million people use
the amazing ring video doorbell to help
protect their homes ring knows that home
security begins at the front door but it
doesn't end there so now they're
extending that same level of security to
the rest of your home with the ring
floodlight camera you know when you try
to break into a home and then the flood
light comes on and
you scamper away into the woods that is
a floodlight a ring has put a camera in
there what's great about them to all my
cool guy friends have ring there they
were all of them do I've given ring to
some friends of mine because it's so
good and it's it's great because you can
see them on on your phone you can be in
your house or on a beach in Boca who
knows and you can talk to them you're
able to communicate scare them away and
it's uploaded into the cloud so you can
share it with your neighbors say watch
out for this guy if the robber steals
your ring doorbell you've already got
the video because it's in the cloud it's
a tremendous product I can't believe how
inexpensive it is for all the value that
you get it is the ultimate in in home
security
with high visibility flood lights
powerful HD cam and put security in your
hands right now don't say I never did
nothing for you save up to $150 off of a
ring of security kit when you go to ring
calm / Knolls que no wles
ring calm / Knolls KO wles what is it I
already told you twice I'll tell you
again ring calm / Noles
okay so trump has identified this issue
it's no coincidence that this is the
issue that he's ending on I mean this is
the final pitch we're now it's now
Thursday we've got Friday Saturday
Sunday Monday Tuesday 5 days left for
the midterm elections his final pitch is
this because he knows it works and it
matters it's a really important issue
and that's the reason it resonates with
the American people President Trump
began his presidential campaign on this
he in many ways it concluded his
presidential campaign on this and he's
concluding the midterms on this as well
it's because it matters and it shows a
degree of political sophistication and
discipline here people like to pretend
that Donald Trump isn't disciplined that
he's reckless he's this emotional guy he
takes everything personally he lashes
out nonsense
nuns that isn't what's happening Trump
is one of the most disciplined
politicians I've ever seen
he stays extraordinarily on message he's
been on message now for three years
almost three years on this issue of
illegal immigration he doesn't really
seem to take things personally he
performs he puts on a show he picks
fights he certainly defends in fights
but he doesn't seem to take things that
personally that's why he's the Teflon
Don
that's why he's able all of the horrific
things that people say about him
imagine all the horrific things they say
he's sexually attracted to his daughter
remember that line of attack they say
he's a traitor to his country he
colluded with Russia's fat he's ugly
he's a baby
the New York Times fantasizes about
assassinating him the New York Times
publishes pictures of him kissing and
getting intimate with Vladimir Putin the
on the list goes on and on and on and he
seems to still enjoy being president you
see him out there these press
conferences you seen with the gaggles
talking to the press he's still up he's
still having a good time if he were
taking this personally he would be
isolated he would be angry he would he
would he wouldn't talk to the press it's
quite the opposite because he seems
confident that he's gonna win and that
confidence that exuberance really I
think has spread out among conservatives
I've been all over the country in the
last week talking to different colleges
talking to different people
the Conservatives I've spoken to seem
pretty confident and the lefties seem
angrier than ever
nowhere is this clearer then on the
mainstream media and on CNN here is a
CNN analyst April Ryan speaking on Don
lemons program and what do you think
that they're making their final
arguments to Trump is making his
arguments for the midterms they're
making theirs what do you think the
final case vote for Democrats because
what's the argument they're making
Trump's a racist take it away and you
know it begs the question he talks about
the press being the innovative the
people it begs the question is he the
enemy of the people by stirring up this
hate by causing people to actually act
on hatred or discrimination against
those to even go as far as killing
people
oh he's stirring up hatred and making
people kill people
first just a note on word usage she says
it begs the question it begs the
question that's not what begs the
question means just a little digression
to beg the question it means to assume
the conclusion that you're trying to
prove that's - that's begging the
question begging the question is not to
ask a question so
there's a little credibility issue here
I I i the minute she said that I thought
this woman probably doesn't know what
she's talking about and I was correct
she's saying that Donald Trump is
stirring up hatred making people want to
kill people making people kill people
the obvious Association she's trying to
make is with this guy who slaughtered 11
people at the synagogue in Pittsburgh
that this is the big story in the
headline she's trying to say that he's
whipping people up into a frenzy to kill
people unfortunately for her even the
left is admitting that any connection
between Trump and the Pittsburgh guy is
false that a connection between Trump
and anti-semitism is false they've
admitted that the New York Times
admitted they said quote there have been
four times as many crimes motivated by
bias against Jews hundred forty two and
all is their have against blacks hate
crimes against Jews have outnumbered
hate crimes targeted transgender people
by a factor of twenty they go on quote
during the past twenty two months not
one person not one person caught or
identified as the aggressor in an
anti-semitic a crime has been associated
with a far-right wing group according to
Mark Mullen RA commanding officer of the
police departments hate crimes task
force not one not one so they can't make
that connection at all as for what other
what other crimes have there been well
we saw a Bernie bro shoot up and almost
killed Steve Scalise shoot up the
Congressional baseball game because
Republicans he didn't like Republicans
opinions on health care and you saw this
wacko ex-stripper guy living in a van in
Florida sent pipe bombs none of which
went off none of which hurt anybody
because he's a lunatic and incompetent
okay I'm willing to grant you the
extreme fringes of both sides there
wackos on the fringe on the right there
wackos in the fringe on the left but the
mainstream we're talking about the
mainstream here that's all that's all
hatred that's all aggression and
violence encouraged by the mainstream of
the Democrat Party and harshly rebuked
by President Trump and every other
Republican all right
what does Bernie Sanders final pitch the
the former future president if not for
Hillary Clinton and the D
see rigging at the former future
president Bernie Sanders Bernie as we
approach the midterms what is your final
vote for Democrats because Trump is a
racist take it away racist the most
racist sexist bigoted president in
American history so racist in fact so
racist is Donald Trump that his support
among black voters has more than doubled
in just the last year that's that's how
racist he is so racist that his support
among Hispanic voters has surged within
the last year
so he's so racist he's so bigoted that
Israel built a train station in his
honor
the Donald Trump train station in
Jerusalem that's how bigoted it is
that's how racist he is let's look at
some other racist president just for
comparison just to see if maybe maybe
some other president has been more
racist than perhaps the least racist
president in history Donald Trump let's
just see no I don't know if he's the
least racist who would be the least
racist in history I don't know that's a
really hard one because the definition
of racism keeps changing that keeps it
according to Democrats if you want to
lower taxes you're a racist so it's very
hard it's very hard to say who's the
most racist and who's the least racist
but what we can't we can point to a few
examples like for example woodrow wilson
democrat president screened Birth of a
Nation in the White House hosted a
screening of Birth of a Nation extolling
the virtues of the Ku Klux Klan in the
White House okay that's nice it can't be
her that's probably racist right how
about LBJ LBJ famously pushed for the
Civil Rights Act so he gets credit for
that he also was by any definition a
racist don't take my word for it the
Nira MSNBC rather has admitted this in a
long analysis of his policies and his
and his
is rhetoric he referred according to his
biographer Robert Caro to the Civil
Rights Act as the n-word bill ninja I'll
say ninja because he says that word a
lot so I'm just gonna you replace it
with ninja you know what word I'm saying
the ninja bill he referred to Asians as
hoards of barbaric yellow dwarves quote
that's a direct quote he would drive to
gas stations when he was a young man
playing on the stereotype that black
people are afraid of snakes apparently
they're afraid of snow everybody I think
is afraid of snakes but I guess there's
a stereotype that black people are in
particular he would drive to gas
stations with a snake in his trunk and
he would get the black gas station
attendant to open up the trunk and be
scared of the snake according to his
biographer Robert dalek he appointed
Thurgood Marshall to the court a very
famous black guy as opposed to a less
famous black guy because he said quote
when I appoint a ninja to the bench I
want everybody to know he's a ninja
that's that's according to LBJ's
biographer Robert dalek Robert Caro
according to LBJ so for Robert Parker
said quote this is LBJ speaking to to
Robert Parker he'd asked him if he
wanted to be called boy or ninja or by
his name the chauffeur obviously said
I'd like to be called by my name
LBJ according to the chauffeur according
to lauded biographer Robert Caro said
quote as long as you're black and you're
gonna be black till the day you die no
one's gonna call you by your GD name so
no matter what you're called ninja you
just let it roll off your back like
water and you'll make it just pretend
you're a GD piece of furniture it's
according to Robert Kira okay and that's
according to the guy that he allegedly
said it to I wouldn't say that Donald
Trump is the most racist president in
history that's my conclusion from all of
that there's a big difference here
between how the Republicans and the
Democrats are running in this race it
tells you a lot about how they feel the
country is going and how the opinions of
the country are going the Republicans
are running on the record of Donald
Trump they are running on their record
Democrats are hiding their record and
running away from their record that's
the difference it's true in virtually
every race in this
going on in the country right now
Republicans are proudly running on the
accomplishments of the last two years
Democrats are hiding their opinions
running away from their opinions trying
to make their political opinions and
views seem more palatable to the
majority of their constituents whom they
consider to be Trump supporters we see
this with Gilliam running down in
Florida he's running to be governor of
Florida here's a video James O'Keefe
doing God's work from Project Veritas
catching the campaign workers admitting
just that's all I'm worried about okay
he's campaigning he's politicking that
last guy Omar Smith apparently went to
college with Gilliam apparently he's an
old pal of Gilliam I don't know why
Gilliam would hire this guy because he's
not a great campaign worker the same
thing down in Georgia Stacey Abrams is
running away from her anti-gun positions
she's saying that you know she oh she
doesn't want to ban guns she doesn't
want to take guns out of people's hands
just to the ar-15 just the most popular
rifle in America just and it's because
the right it's so powerful but she's not
this she's pretending to be a moderate
it's and it's it's a flat-out lie she's
far from a moderate and she's she's
lying about statistics she's saying that
the ar-15 is a weapon of mass
destruction that it's too dangerous to
have in civilian hands just one little
statistic to keep in mind in the year
2014 there were 50 562 deaths from
handguns in the United States only 248
from rifles of any kind actually it's
likely many more deaths are from
handguns but there are some there are a
couple thousand in the category where
they don't know they don't know how
which gun was used in that crime so what
is it 20 times more deaths homicides
from and I think it's death so it
includes suicides as well but over 20
times more deaths from handguns than any
rifles of any kind a Harry Reid right
now is backing off of his former
positions in 93 he introduced a bill to
take away birthright citizenship the
same exact proposal that Donald Trump
trolled Democrats into opposing just
yesterday then he came out today he said
you know I said that but then my wife
immediately told me it was wrong and I
agreed it was wrong
BS because then a year later Harry we
doubled down on his on his support for
that in a column for the LA Times and
said that we should take away birthright
citizenship running away from that
finally liya Wafaa
folk ohonta herself running away from
what she did as she exploited Christine
Ford and the the confirmation for Brett
Kavanaugh here very quickly is lieth and
getting caught with a major ethics
complaint during a debate I would I
would like to drill down and what
representative deal said the the
fundraising while the vote was being
taken on the cabin right did you or did
you not do the end actually I don't know
and I don't know what the there an
ethics committee plan has been filed
about a fundraiser and then I will I
will check into it but I don't know you
have any response to that I don't
representative do chef Neil uh no I have
no please let her keep hanging herself
that's fine please let her keep
humiliating herself I don't look into it
I don't Trump's a racist yeah that's it
those are your choices this is your
choices in this election great booming
economy relative peace abroad record low
joblessness a president with no evidence
that he's discriminated against anybody
total total lies greater freedom greater
equality greater justice for all or
Trump's a racist rap rap those are your
two choices those are the two campaigns
I hope that the American voters pay
attention on Election Day we gotta say
goodbye to face
book in YouTube please come join me in
this leftist here's silo that we now
find ourselves in at least you can get
your leftist ears tumblr go to daily
wire it's ten bucks a month hundred
dollars for an annual membership you get
me the Andrew Clavin show the Ben
Shapiro show questions in the mailbag
another Kingdom relate so another
Kingdom you'll get the audio anybody can
listen to the audio on Fridays but
you'll get to view it the the Monday
before it gets a few all the beautiful
artwork it's super cool getting a lot of
great attention and really good numbers
so check it out and the leftist years
tumblr hopefully we're all gonna need it
on Tuesday go to daily wire comm we'll
be right back with the mailbag
all right first question from Evan hey
Michael I was wondering what you think
Trump's greatest accomplishments have
been so far in his presidency keep up
the good work all of the show Thanks
the greatest accomplishment probably the
most long-lasting accomplishment is
destroying the credibility of the
mainstream media or rather exposing the
uncredible 'ti of the mainstream media
because he didn't destroy it they
destroyed it themselves and they have no
credibility no question about that but
he triggered them as Jon Stewart was
saying the other day he triggered them
into exposing and he triggered them into
exposing themselves as hack partisan
narcissists who take everything
personally who pretend that they are the
most important glorious heroes on the
face of the earth and he showed them for
what they are which is partisan hack
narcissists that's the most important
the second most important are the judges
the judges are so important he's gotten
a lot more judges through than anybody
thought he would at this point two on
the Supreme Court countless others at
the federal courts and they will shape
in large part how the country is
governed in in some ways this is too bad
because we want our country to be
governed out of the legislature and then
out of the executive we want judges to
call balls and strikes but the left has
weaponized the legislature for so long
and President Trump has been able to
undo a lot of that and we now have
institutions like the Federalist Society
and other legal societies that can
ensure that we get fair serious good
players on the benches president Trump
has done that cocaine Mitch gets a lot
of credit for that too
that's an amazing legacy and that will
long long outlive his presidency
even if he were heaven forfend impeach
tomorrow it would long outlive his
presidency and it's it's excellent work
he's done great on everything else too
and there's some signal the one weakness
is that they haven't reformed
entitlements or made moves really in
that direction there's been some signal
recently that they might do it on
everything else he gets an A+ on every
other question he gets an A+ but those
two are the most important from Dan
Michael I like the Brett Kavanaugh
costume but isn't gray hair
black-faced kind of offensive this is a
great question I suppose now I've been
trying not to admit this in public but
because you've accused me of cultural
appropriation I will have to admit this
my head of hair is 1/1000 24th gray it
is it is what the other day I was in the
mirror of his coming I found one little
gray hair right here and so I my hair is
more gray than Elizabeth Warren is
Indian and but I think as a result now I
can go out and portray myself as grayer
than Brett Kavanaugh because I am one
1,024 gray a gray American great
question though thank you and I'm
actually it's a real burden that I can
its off my shoulders now that I can make
that confession to you from Benjamin
dear Michael king of cough FA earlier
this month a my girlfriend and I broke
up because she felt that God was telling
her we needed to take a break heard that
one before buddy I'm sorry to hear it he
goes on so she can deal with anxiety in
her life I was not hearing that at all
in fact I was beginning to think that I
wanted to marry her
the past month has been very hard for me
I'm wondering if I try to move on or
wait and see if she comes back after she
works through her anxiety I don't want
to give up on our relationship but I
don't think my heart could take waiting
months for her only to find out she's
already moved on any advice would be
appreciated thanks love the show oh
where to begin you should not give up
entirely it depends I don't know the
details of this breakup first of all she
just broke up with you
it's not because God told her to it's
not because of some transcendent
experience she broke up with you she
broke up with you you didn't want to
break up and she broke up with you
period
so you got dumped okay now you really
like the girl and you don't want to take
no for an answer on having a
relationship with her okay fair enough
just because the girl broke up with you
doesn't mean that you won't get back
together at some point in the future you
should be around but you should not wait
around
Ovid the great ancient writer has a good
book called Romania Amore's the cure for
love
he has a lot of a lot of suggestions for
how to get over a relationship to get
over a love affair and I won't say them
here because they're probably too vulgar
for this family show but you can give it
a read and entertain those ideas if you
like you should be around but not wait
around go on dates with other girls go
see other girls go talk to them go meet
a girl at a bar or in class or at
whatever hobby you do or on one of the
apps or something meet girls go out you
got dumped you're single go talk to
girls go explore a lot of fish in the
sea if you really really like the girl
be around maybe when she wises up comes
to her senses then you guys can get back
together but don't wait around because
no girl wants some schlub who's just
waiting around it seems it doesn't seem
very manly women want a guy who's
behaving at all in a manly way I'm not
exactly an Adonis myself but there are
certain things that you can do to better
your situation and that's one of them be
around sure but definitely don't wait
around from Andy hey Michael I've got a
Socratic seminar in my teaching class
next week discussing weather literacy
should be a right or not I disagree
because it's a good it's a good and
places an obligation on taxpayers and
others are there any other points that I
could bring up to support my side since
I know for a fact I'll be in a small
minority Andy yeah it's the question it
is literacy a right is a nonsense it is
a no there's no bad but it doesn't mean
anything so I'm a little stumped on how
you could even respond to it
literacy is a skill you have to learn
how to read you can't use you you say oh
I skipped every class from first grade
to college and so I don't know how to
read or do anything else but I demand it
it's my right no it's a skill it's not a
right you have you know I think that
whitewater rafting is a right it's a
right so I'm gonna go do it I think you
know I think that surfing is a right so
I can't understand why I'm not very good
at surfing because it's a right isn't it
no it's a skill and it requires work and
it requires character and virtue and
discipline to learn how to read
it's a skill unfortunately in this
country a lot of people are treating
skills as though they are rights which
is why they can't do anything and they
can't get a job or they get the job that
they want it's a skill and if your
classmates and teachers had had acquired
the skill and the of literacy and the
other skills of Education maybe they
wouldn't ask such a stupid question from
Ryan if the founders were alive today
and saw how the federal government has
expanded would they rebel against it no
they wouldn't I know that's an unpopular
opinion I know that even among
conservative and certainly libertarian
circles we say oh they would be shocked
they would rebel there'd be a revolution
no they wouldn't
the Federalists understood that we
needed a robust federal government
Alexander Hamilton favored a monarchy
rather than the presidency and Thomas
Jefferson the head of the
anti-federalists and then ultimately the
Jeffersonian Democrats out Federalists
did the Federalists when he made the
Louisiana Purchase and vastly expanded
the scope of federal territory and of
the the size of the country in the
federal government so no I don't think
they would they would have a lot to
criticize about our government but I
don't think the sheer size of it would
be a source of criticism and I don't
think they would rebel against it for
that way I think really the Federalists
and the anti-federalists and the
Jeffersonian Democrats which which the
latter became I think they would they
would sort of understand it because the
natural progression by the way of
government is to grow even among those
great men it is to grow it is to take
too much power so I don't think they'd
be surprised at all should we whittle it
down would they think we should whittle
it down very probably but I don't think
that they would they would exactly
revolt against it from Brett dear
Michael do you like beer
no I'm kidding it's not it's not from
that bet Brett dear Michael do you think
that the mail bombs will have any effect
on the midterms thanks a ton Brett no I
don't I don't think they will I feared
that they would I don't think that it's
been reflected in polling that it's
stopped Republican momentum or that it
has turned momentum in favor of
Democrats and the bombs didn't go off I
think this guy seems to be a total
lunatic who was homeless living in a van
ex-stripper clearly had psychological
problems
don't think people care I think there
have been a lot of distractions look if
someone had been injured or killed maybe
it would have but because these were
awful bombs that don't in many cases
couldn't have even detonated apparently
according to the New York Times I don't
think people are taking it that
seriously which is good it's good
because people weren't hurt and it's
good because it won't apparently hurt us
with the elections this election is
going to be about issues and Republicans
have made issues out of illegal
immigration law and order and the judges
Democrats have shrieked and howled and
cried racism and that's their issue
they're running against Trump and it
puts them in a bad position because you
can't win a campaign against somebody
and I think you'll see in in the places
where Democrats do win seats it's
because they'll have offered something
other than just racism that's not that's
not gonna work you can't run against
something from Riley on Monday when you
were talking about the death penalty my
roommate and I we were both Catholic and
my roommate was listening along with me
he said that what you were saying went
against Catholic doctrine he stated that
killing for killing was textbook eye for
an eye I would like to know if you could
prove definitively that the death
penalty does not go against doctrine
Thanks
I sometimes listen to your show of
course his his opinion the problem with
his opinion is that it is not correct
though it is a popular misconception
today st. Paul writes definitively about
the legitimacy of the state in capital
punishment the legitimacy of execution
by the civil authority st. Agustin
writes about the same thing father of
the church Saint Thomas Aquinas doctor
of the church writes about the same
thing the Council of Trent in the 16th
century upheld the legitimacy of capital
punishment by the civil authority
blessed Pius the 9th blessed Pius the
9th carried out capital punishment or
sanctioned it as Pope and Pope Pius the
12th was so supportive of the Nuremberg
trials that were executing Nazi war
criminals that he sent his own lawyers
there to hasten them up he said we wish
to see this completed as quickly as
possible
and he sent his own lawyers to make sure
those Nazis got what was coming toward
them even John Paul the second by the
way acknowledged to the legitimacy of
the four different types of punishment
that we
talked about on the show the other day
even while personally discouraging the
use of capital punishment and Pope
Benedict the last Bennett SS Pope put it
very very well which is he said quote if
a Catholic were to be at odds with the
Holy Father on the application of
capital punishment around the decision
to wage war he would not for that reason
be considered unworthy to present
himself to receive Holy Communion which
is to say there can be a legitimate
difference of opinion among Catholics on
capital punishment I think clearly
scripture sacred tradition the history
of the Catholic Church upholds the
perfect legitimacy of capital punishment
but there can be legitimate disagreement
there Pope Francis has confused this
issue tremendously with his highly
confusing revision to the Catechism but
I'm not I'm not going to concern myself
with that because because even he wasn't
able to suggest that the capital
punishment is intrinsically evil because
obviously it's not from or do we have
time for one more we got time for one
more last one okay fine from our own
dear dr. Cerf effe I'm one of those
Indians on whose behalf white leftists
are presuming to be offended about a poo
what responsibility would you say I as
an American conservative have to speak
out against this fake outrage any
suggestions on how I can do so without
being labeled a self racist British
collaborator or whatever the Indian
equivalent of Uncle Tom is or is
fighting the left on this a losing
battle thank you come again great great
point I think that you should speak up I
think that it's very important for
racial ethnic minorities who consider
themselves right-wing who reject the
identity politics of the left and of the
Democrats just speak up about it because
there's just more credibility when it
comes from the racial minorities what
the left does is as a bunch of shrieking
white millennial women pretending to be
offended on behalf of racial minorities
and they get away with it because the
only people who can
point out that that's absurd who are
speaking out very often our old white
dudes in the Republican Party of the
conservative movement with with some day
I mean you've now seen certain people
coming out obviously Kanye West nor the
Maggie had in the Oval Office and talked
about liberals breaking up the black
family so there are exceptions but it's
it has a great impact and I think it's
very important to do it and you will be
called an uncle deepak or whatever the
Indian version of Uncle Tom is you will
be you absolutely will be you'll be
called a racist against your own people
they that's what you got to deal with
and the the left is mucky and vicious
and slings insults and calumny all the
time in fact that's their only argument
in the 2018 midterm elections that's the
price of doing business I won't blame
you if you don't do it but you should
speak out okay that's our show we got a
lot more coming up on Monday and of
course Tuesday and we'll be following
the election results on Tuesday as well
in the meantime listen to another
kingdom it's a very fun and super cool
and it's certainly the last time I'll
ever work as a performer in Hollywood so
make sure that you check it out in the
meantime I will see you on Monday I'm
Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Noel's show
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
seniya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by Mike core Amina hair
and makeup is by Joshua ov era the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018